singer are Kelly's behavior toward women
is once again the focus of national
attention a new TV series laid out the
history of abuse allegations against him
surviving our Kelly is what it's called
it's a six-part documentary cues the
grammy-winner of emotional physical and
sexual abuse vladimir duthiers vera
streaming network cbsn is here with more
on this story I started watching it but
it is very disturbing it is stripping
indeed I've got through almost all the
episodes yeah me too Wow
despite several previous allegations of
abusive behavior Robert Kelly or as the
world knows him our Kelly has bounced
back repeatedly but one accuser tells us
she now believes things this time may be
different this isn't the first time
music icon our Kelly has faced
allegations of abuse by multiple women
Robert feels as if he's invincible but
they've never been laid out like this
all these things that I didn't want to
be I became a lifetime docu-series
surviving our Kelly featured stark
interviews with women accusing the
singer of being controlling and both
physically and sexually abusive in some
cases when they were teenage girls he
asked me how old I was and I told him I
was 17 I guess I felt like I was tricked
into something kitty Jones detailed how
she claims Kelly would restrict her
movements slap her face and force her to
have sex with women he picked me up from
the airport I got in the car and he
began beating me in the car
she tells CBS News she's sharing her
story because she believes Kelly may
still be mistreating others I really
want him to get some help I do in July
Kelly released a nearly 20 minute long
single titled I admit in it he sings
that he made some mistakes but never
disrespected or abused women you may
have opinions
entitled to your opinion but really am I
supposed to go to jail to lose my career
because your pain Kelley's career has
thrived since allegations first surfaced
in the mid-1990s the three-time Grammy
winner has continued to perform despite
protests and is working on a new album
however the executive producer of
surviving r.kelly has said it was
incredibly difficult to get people who
had collaborated with Kelly to come
forward to musicians who did appear in
the doc you series chance the rapper
making a song with our Kelly was a
mistake I'm John Legend he should be
ashamed of himself and I hope there's
some justice done to him at some point
Kitty Jones says she hopes surviving art
Kelly will lead to change I think
putting us all on you know camera this
was the first time it was actually in
people's faces I'm just grateful that
they gave us a voice our Kelly has not
commented on the new series but has
consistently denied all allegations of
physical and sexual misconduct he was
previously acquitted on child
pornography charges as for Kitty Jones a
representative for Kelly previously
publicly described their relationship as
consensual involvement between two
adults it is very disturbing upsetting
the thing it makes you wonder why he's
not in jail if you believe what these
women are saying he's been in this has
been in the public eye for over 20 years
that's unbelievable that it's only
coming out really it's dope for saying
as women have a voice that's right